>> Hannity: ED HENRY JOINING
US NOW WITH A REACTION, THE
AUTHOR OF "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
BEST SELLER, TRUMPS AMERICA, THE
TRUTH ABOUT OUR NATION.
FORMER SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE,
NEWT GINGRICH.
AND EVERY CASE, TONIGHT WAS
GLARING IN THIS CLIENT OF HIS.
NO COOPERATION FROM THE VERY
PEOPLE THAT THEY SAID WOULD
COOPERATE.
>> YES.
I WILL TAKE YOU UP FROM 30
SECONDS AWAY FROM THIS.
ALL OF US SHOULD RECOGNIZE THE
LAST 24 HOURS PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
THE ONE WITH AN ENORMOUS VICTORY
WITH CANADA AND MEXICO.
IN THE MIDDLE OF ALL THIS NOISE.
BIG THINGS ARE HAPPENING TO
CREATE A LOT OF NEW JOBS, TO
KEEP THE ECONOMY GOING.
THE PRESIDENT IS DELIVERING AND
HE IS GETTING RESULTS.
>> Hannity: IT IS NOT
INSIGNIFICANT.
THIS TO ME AS A REAL THREAT.
ONE OF THE FOUNDATIONAL
PRINCIPLES WE SHARE, ALL OF US.
THIS IS WHY I SAY DOES NOT
REPUBLICAN OR DEMOCRAT.
>> HERE'S WHAT I DON'T
UNDERSTAND COME I HAVEN'T HAD
THIS IN A LONG TIME.
THEY TALK ABOUT THIS DEAL THAT
HE MADE COMPANY GIVE UP NOTHING.
REPUBLICAN SOMETIMES HAVE THIS
PASSION FOR BEING STUPID.
FLAKE GOT NOTHING OUT OF THAT,
NOTHING.
PLAYS THIS GAME.
LET ME SEE I CAN RIP YOU OFF
AGAIN.
DIDN'T HE SAYS, WOULD YOU PLEASE
RIP ME OFF A LITTLE BIT MORE?
THERE IS A REASON PEOPLE GET FED
UP WITH THE STUFF.
LINDSEY GRAHAM WE HAD AN A WHILE
AGO IS THE MOST EFFECTIVE GUY ON
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
HE TOLD THE TRUTH.
I THINK WE AS THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE HAVE TO STAND UP AND SAY
THEY DON'T WANT A COUNTRY THAT
IS DOMINATED BY THESE KINDS OF
PEOPLE.
I THINK IT HAS A REALLY SERIOUS
THREAT.
>> Hannity: WHAT DID YOU THINK
OF HIS IDEA THAT IF THEY FALL
SHORT, THE SHOULD BE A ELECTION
AGAIN QUESTION WORK ON THIS
ISSUE?
>> I THINK IT IS A GOOD IDEA.
>> Hannity: AND THE PRESIDENT
WOULD RENOMINATE?
>> Tucker: I THINK IT IS A
GOOD IDEA.
THE ALABAMA SENATOR WHO
SUPPOSEDLY NOT A LIBERAL DOES
COME OUT TO WORK WITH THE LEFT,
JO DONNELLY REPRESENTED THE
VICE PRESIDENT'S HOME STATE, WHO
WILL VOTE WITH THE LEFT.
YOU HAVE HIGH CAMP IN THE STATE
WHICH REPUBLICANS HAVE CARRIED A
16 OUT OF THE LAST 17
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGNS.
THEY WILL PROBABLY WOOD FOR THE
LEFT.
WE HAVE 15 OUT OF 17.
I THINK IMAGINE IS GOING TO VOTE
FOR BRETT KAVANAUGH.
I TELL YOU WHAT, IF HE DOESN'T
VOTE FOR BRETT KAVANAUGH, THEY
ARE DEFINITELY SHOULD BRING
BRETT KAVANAUGH BACK UP BECAUSE
AFTER THE ELECTION, MANSION WILL
HAVE DISAPPEARED.
>> Hannity: ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS WE HAVE GOTTEN TO USE
TO, I WARN MY AUDIENCE EVERY TWO
OR THREE YEARS.
RACIST, SEXIST, HOMOPHOBES,
ISLAM HOPES, KILLED CHILDREN AND
KILLED GRANDMA.
I WATCHED YOU GO THROUGH
THIS.
I WAS THERE.
I SAW IT ALL.
THERE IS A CERTAIN EMBRACING OF
SLANDER NOW.
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHOSE FAMILY
IS HEARING THIS.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT THEY ARE
SAYING.
>> THEY SCORE POINTS WITH THEIR
CRAZED FRENCH
THAT IS PEOPLE ARE SAYING.
THIS ELECTION IS FALL IS ABOUT
TWO AMERICAS.
IN AMERICA THAT THINKS BULLYING
YOU AT A RESTAURANT, PULLING YOU
IN AN ELEVATOR, HARASSING YOU,
DESTROYING YOU, SMEARING YOU,
SHAMING YOU IN FRONT OF YOUR
CHILDREN IS FINE BECAUSE THEY
ARE MORALLY IMPURE.
>> Hannity: I NEVER HEAR A
SINGLE POSITIVE AGENDA ITEM THAT
IS GOING TO BENEFIT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE FROM THE DEMOCRATS.
THIS IS WHAT I HEAR, THEY WANT
TO IMPEACH TRUMP THEY WANT AND
BLISS INVESTIGATIONS, THEY WANT
TO KEEP OBAMACARE WHICH IS BEEN
A DISASTER.
THEY WANT TO GET RID OF I.C.E
AND OPEN BORDERS.
THEY WANT THE CRUMBS BACK.
THEY WANT THE TAX CUTS BACK.
THEY WANT THEM BACK.
HOW DO REPUBLICANS DEFEAT
HISTORY AND THEY SAID THAT IT IS
ONLY HAPPEN THROUGH TABS IN THE
LAST 100 YEARS.
THE PARTY GETS THE POWER OF THE
WHITE HOUSE.
AND THEN HOLD ONTO POWER AND THE
MIDTERMS.
>> THE SAME WAY WE WANTED 2016.
WE GET MORE VOTES WHERE IT
MATTERS.
THE FACT IS, I WILL GO OUT ON A
LIMB, I THINK ELECTION NIGHT
THIS YEAR WILL BE WORSE THAN
2016.
I THINK THERE'S GOING TO BE A
SHOCK.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY FOR
EXAMPLE, CAN REDUCE THE
CANDIDATE FOR CALIFORNIA WANTS
TO HAVE GOVERNMENT RUN
HEALTH CARE TO PAY FOR
HEALTH CARE FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
>> Hannity: 10 MILLION.
>> THAT IS THIS YEAR.
WHEN WORKERS GO TO CALIFORNIA,
AND EVERY PERSON GET SICK ON THE
PLANET WILL BE TOLD TO GO TO
CALIFORNIA APPEAR THEY WANT TO
TAKE CARE OF YOU.
I THINK THOSE KINDS OF POLICIES
>> Hannity: BY THE WAY
>> Hannity: BY THE WA,
>> Hannity: BY THE WAT
>> Hannity: BY THE WAE
>> Hannity: BY THE WAM
>> Hannity: BY THE WAS
>> Hannity: BY THE WAT
>> Hannity: BY THE WAI
>> Hannity: BY THE WAP
>> Hannity: BY THE WAR
>> Hannity: BY THE WAA
ARE SO UNSUSTAINABLE.
>> Hannity: BY THE WAT
INDICATOR IS THAT WE WANT A SEAT
IN SOUTH TEXAS.
53% HISPANIC IN    IN A MOMENT T
WE HAVE NOT HAD IT 139 YEARS,
53% HISPANIC IN    IN A MOMENT O
LIMIT THE DEMOCRATS FAVOR TAX.
ABORTIONS, THEY JUST LEFT.
THEY SAID WE ARE NOT WITH YOU.
>> Hannity: IF THIS DOESN'T
AWAKEN THE PACE OF THE
CONSERVATIVE MOVEMENT FOR THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY, TRUMP
SUPPORTERS, I DON'T KNOW WHAT
WILL.
>> I DIFFERENT SAY TO ME TODAY,
THEY HAVE NEVER SEEN AS MANY
CONSERVATIVES AS ANGRY AS THEY
ARE NOW.
IT IS WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE BRETT
KAVANAUGH AND YOU LOOK AT HIS
TWO DAUGHTERS AND HIS WIFE AND
YOU THINK, THESE BAD
HUMAN BEINGS.
THEY ARE WILLING TO DO THIS TO
THIS FAMILY.
>> Hannity: WITHOUT ANY
COOPERATION AT ALL.
IT IS SCARY.